Ja Leute, Moin! Schon so viele am Start. Ich fahre gerade den Streamingrechner hoch.
Besser gesagt, ich habe gerade überhaupt meinen Rechner eingeschaltet.
Lull.
Exzellent.
Was ist das denn?
Ist das ein Elefant?
Ein Kekomrit-Elefant?
So, Streamingrechner startet.
So, ich habe mich schon eine Stunde oder eineinhalb Stunden bewegt heute.
Sachen gibt's.
Muss ja nicht noch dicker werden, als ich eh schon bin.
Pepefett.
Lull.
So, mein Sound ist irgendwie gerade weg, aber ich glaube, ihr hört noch was, ne?
Ja, jetzt ist er wieder da.
In jedem Fall war ich noch einkaufen, da war heute richtig voll.
Erstmal hier MonkaCorona gemacht, als ich wieder daheim war.
Heute Abend, Leute, heute Abend ist, ich bin jetzt auch nur kurz da.
Quasi Mittagspause-Stream.
Heute Abend ist ja Apple Event 2020, ist hier, wie heißt das?
WWDC.
Was gibt's hier?
Predictions.
Mal gucken, was ist heute Abend.
iOS 14.
Leaker Predicts.
Okay, da wird immer alles geleakt.
Macrumors.
Okay, was rumort der Mac?
Mein Mac rumort übrigens nichts, weil ich habe keinen.
Who cares, was juckt mich, was irgend so ein Typ auf Twitter schreibt?
Vielleicht ein Monitorhalter für 1000.
Ja.
Da habe ich auch gerade dran gedacht.
Monitorhalter für 1000 Euro.
VESA Mount für 200 Euro.
Excellent.
Top.
Okay.
Predictions.
Okay, Predictions.
Was wird predicted?
Gucken wir heute Abend.
Heute Abend 19 Uhr.
Gucken wir das zusammen.
Ich hoffe, man darf das restreamen.
Mittlerweile mehr online als offline.
Ja, ich hätte das.
Hättet ihr mir das mal von einem Jahr erzählt oder so?
Da hätte ich gedacht, null verarscht mich nicht, da ich so viel am streamen bin.
Mittlerweile kommt mir fast ein Tag ohne streamen an.
So vor, als hätte ich nichts gemacht.
Ist schon merkwürdig, ne?
Und man muss sagen, das schlägt sich auch in Subscriberzahlen und allem nieder.
Also ich glaube, ich hatte noch nie so viele Subscriber wie aktuell.
Ich glaube sogar mehr als Weihnachten.
Ich glaube sogar mehr als an Weihnachten.
Oder knapp, vielleicht knapp weniger.
Aber auf jeden Fall nicht viel weniger.
Okay, iOS 14.
Ja gut, da rechne ich ehrlich gesagt auch mit, weil ich meine, die sind schon bei iOS
13.5.
Na, da muss ja iOS 14 mal jetzt kommen.
Das halte ich für nahezu sicher.
Build in Translator.
Okay, das halte ich für gar nicht so abwegig.
Translator, Machine Learning gestützte Translator Sachen sind voll im Trend.
Hier DeepL ist ja so der neueste Hype, was das angeht.
Wir gucken mal, was passiert.
Wir gucken mal.
Wir gucken mal, ob der, ob der Deutsch, ob der Twitch Chat kann.
Der Twitch Chat ist besonders cute Chat heute.
Ayaya.
Okay.
Translate in Englisch.
Moment.
Translate.
Englisch.
German in Englisch.
Der Twitch Chat.
Moment.
Der Twitch Chat ist especially cute Chat today.
Ey, so die Übersetzung ist ziemlich gut.
Mein Chef will wissen, was ich gerade für Programmiervideos sag.
AI.
Python Deep Learning AI.
Habt ihr mal die GitHub Language Statistik angeguckt?
Ähm.
Find das eigentlich ganz interessant.
Also ich meine, es ist nicht verwunderlich, dass auf GitHub JavaScript auf dem ersten
JavaScript auf dem ersten Platz ist, ne.
JavaScript ist Dings.
Aber das muss man echt sagen.
Äh.
Dass Python gleich auf dem zweiten Platz ist, okay, finde ich jetzt auch nicht so überrascht.
Aber Java.
Und wisst ihr, warum Java?
Aber erstens gibt es natürlich schon viele bestehende Produkte und sonst was.
Aber die Chinesen.
Die Chinesen stehen unglaublich auf Java.
Ich weiß nicht so genau, warum.
Vielleicht mögen die Microsoft nicht und denken sich, okay, bevor wir mit C Sharp anfangen,
machen wir lieber Java.
Aber.
Die Chinesen, die stehen total auf Java Zeug.
Wenn ihr mal auf, wenn ihr mal auf GitHub guckt.
Äh.
Wenn ihr mal GitHub Trending guckt, dann werdet ihr feststellen, dass die, dass erstens sau
viele chinesische Sachen trenden.
Einmal die Woche.
Ihr sau viel chinesische Sachen trenden.
Hier sowas da.
Und Spring Boot.
Es ist Java.
Fast alles, was chinesisch ist und trendet, ist Java.
Die Chinesen.
Die sind 15 Jahre hinterher, schreibt der Patrick.
Vielleicht sind die auch 15 Jahre vorne dran.
Und der Trend der Zukunft ist, ist Java.
Das wäre natürlich.
Wird mir nicht so gefallen.
Man weiß ja nie.
Aber man muss mal gucken.
Alles mit.
Also 90 Prozent der Sachen mit chinesischen Zeichen auf GitHub sind, ist Java.
Okay.
C++.
Ich habe nichts gesagt.
Aber das meiste ist Java.
China.
China Zeug.
Okay.
JavaScript.
Zählt nicht.
Java.
Das hatten wir aber schon.
Ja.
Die haben eine Brille auf.
Genau.
Weil sie nicht C Sharp können.
Oh, der ist so alt und schlecht eigentlich.
Ne.
Ja.
Ruby ist auch erstaunlich, dass es noch so weit oben ist.
Aber das liegt wahrscheinlich an den 30 Milliarden Ruby Projekten, die auf GitHub erstellt wurden
und keiner mehr pflegt.
Go.
Okay.
Verstehe ich.
C++.
Ja.
C++ bin ich nicht so scharf drauf.
Aber gerade Java.
Ich glaube, das liegt zum größten Teil mit an den Chinesen, dass so viel neues Zeug in
Java aus China kommt.
Da stehen die auf Schmerzen.
Ja.
Tja.
End of Function Zero.
Ich glaube, dass Java und C Sharp in Zukunft durch nichts ersetzt werden.
Ich glaube eher, dass es umgedreht ist, dass Sachen in Java und C Sharp eher die Sachen
sind, die was anderes ersetzen werden.
Weil C++ ist ja komplette Qual mittlerweile.
Die einzigen Leute, die C++, ich will nicht mal sagen gerne machen.
Ich weiß nicht, ob es irgendjemand auf der Welt gibt, der wirklich C++ gerne macht.
Vielleicht.
Vielleicht der eine oder andere Competitive Programmer oder so.
Aber es wird nicht so viel geben, die C++ gerne machen.
Die einzigen aber, die C++ halt tagtäglich wirklich noch machen müssen aktuell, sind
zum größten Teil Spieleprogrammierer.
Und selbst da, dank Unity, ist immer mehr C Sharp am Start.
Ist C++ losing popularity?
Ja, zum Glück.
Zum Glück.
Es ist ja auch absolut eklig.
Also C Sharp ist garantiert nicht am Sterben.
C Sharp geht durch die Decke im Vergleich zu früher.
Also da muss man das Microsoft mal zugutehalten, dass die ihr komplettes oder nicht komplettes,
dass da mal 90% .NET Core und C Sharp und alle Sachen, die sie machen, open sourced haben,
war eine sehr gute Idee.
Seitdem, die letzten vier, fünf Jahre, geht C Sharp steil nach oben.
Könnt ihr euch noch daran erinnern, wo Microsoft GitHub gekauft hat?
Das ist ja erst zwei Jahre ungefähr her.
Da haben so viele Leute Panik geschoben, so nach dem Motto, oh mein Gott, Microsoft kauft
GitHub.
Wir müssen alle unsere Projekte von GitHub abziehen.
Und jetzt sind ein paar Leute nach GitLab, sind zu GitLab rüber und haben keine Contributors
mehr.
Oh, man muss es eigentlich gar nicht durchstehen.
Habe ich auch gedacht, Leute, einfach mal nicht so viel Panik schieben und abwarten.
Max, wirst du bald wieder Vollzeit arbeiten?
Nö, warum sollte ich das denn machen?
Go hat bald Generics, habe ich auch gelesen, ja.
Das aber das erzählen sie seit fünf Jahren schon.
Nee, nee, also ich gehe nicht wieder Vollzeit arbeiten.
Gar kein Fall.
Wenn schon, gehe ich eher weniger arbeiten.
Bevor ich wieder Vollzeit arbeiten gehe.
Also die Chancen, dass ich
drei Tage die Woche arbeite
von vier
anstatt wieder fünf Tage
von vier, das ist dann größer.
Der Depp 1899
ist das Geburtsjahr.
Okay, das war schlecht.
Das war Painschamp Witz.
Ich gebe es zu.
Ich finde bloß gerade das passende Emote nicht.
Wo ist mein... Ja, hier ist er.
Painschamp.
Sagt ihm,
er hat Open Source den Arsch gerettet.
Ja, wenn man es mal so will,
im Prinzip rettet mir das auch tagtäglich den Arsch.
Ich verwende auf der Arbeit
den ganzen Tag
Manjaro mit i3 WM
und zum größten Teil
Open Source Zeug. Das einzige, was ich
regelmäßig verwenden muss, was nicht Open Source ist,
ist halt Remote Windows Desktop
mit Outlook drauf.
Das war's.
Was machst du in deiner Freizeit,
wenn du gerade nicht streamst?
Essen.
Nee,
ich überlege mir,
was ich streamen könnte für Themen
und ich überlege mir, ob ich mir nicht mal wieder ein Video mache.
Ansonsten programmiere ich ab und zu
Offstream oder bin Sachen am Spielen.
In letzter Zeit mache ich tatsächlich
ab und zu mal Sport.
Ich weiß, das glaubt mir keiner, aber
langsam aber sicher
muss das mal sein.
Ich arbeite weiter
an meiner
Liste, warum C++ die schlechteste
Programmiersprache ist.
Da kommen täglich neue Punkte dazu.
Nee,
so schlimm ist es auch nicht.
Ja, das war's.
Und ich hätte ja gerne mal wieder ein MMO,
was ich richtig durchsuchten kann,
aber wahrscheinlich ist es für euch gar nicht so gut,
weil wenn ich irgendein MMO hätte, was ich durchsuchten kann,
würde ich weniger streamen.
Video machen habe ich ja eh schon komplett
eingestellt in letzter Zeit.
Wo Classic?
Nee, nee, nee, nee, nee.
Ist die Liste Open Source? Welche Liste?
Welche Liste?
Wie sieht's mit Familienplanung aus?
Gar nicht.
Was soll ich da planen?
Ich plane, dass ich nix plane.
Ich plane auch, dass ich hoffentlich
nix planen muss.
Also mit Kinder kannst du, nee, nee, nee.
Also erstens,
für Kinder brauchst du
zwei Leute. Und drittens,
ich mag keine Menschen und ich mag schon
vor allem gar keine Kinder.
Okay, vielleicht jetzt meine eigenen werden,
vielleicht wär das dann nicht so schlimm.
Aber ich hab da überhaupt keinen Bock.
Ach, jetzt hab ich mir überlegt, was das kostet.
Ist ja nicht nur stressig,
es ist auch noch teuer.
Nee, nee, nee, hör mal auf.
Das muss nicht sein.
Ich mein, ich steh jetzt ganz gut da, ja?
Ich hab zwei bis drei Einnahmequellen,
sag mal zwei Einnahmequellen.
Ähm, ich hab ganz gut Geld
gespart, ich hab ein Haus.
Warum soll ich jetzt Kinder kriegen und alles wieder in den Sand setzen,
was ich an Kohle am Start hab?
Äh.
Das ist ja, wär ja komplett bescheuert.
Ich meine, klar,
sowas kann immer mal schnell, schnell, äh, sehen.
Das kann sich ändern, man weiß,
man weiß ja nie, was in Zukunft, äh, passiert.
Ja.
Aber ich hab's nicht vor.
Wirklich nicht.
Also Depp, äh, ich wollt grad sagen,
Depp, äh, 18,99,
wahrscheinlich ist es sogar noch relativ wenig, was das kostet.
Ich glaube, das ist wahrscheinlich sogar noch viel teurer.
Das ist wahrscheinlich
das Mindeste, was du machen musst, dass, dass,
dass das überlebt bis zum 18. Jahr.
Ähm, äh, wenn du willst,
dass das eine gute, äh, gute Bildung,
gute Ausbildung, äh,
auch mal die ein oder anderen Sachen erlebt
und das es dem Kind an sich, äh, gut geht und das auch
was hat, dann ist es wahrscheinlich eine ganze,
ganze Ecke mehr.
Und wenn, das würde ich dann auch machen, wenn,
wenn's soweit wäre, aber ich, äh,
will gar nicht, dass es soweit kommt.
Ja, aktuell ist das, Nico, das stimmt schon,
aktuell, äh, also, ich bin niemand, der hier
der große, große Investor-Guru ist, ne?
Also, BWL-Wirtschafts-Zeug
ist, ist, finde, ist nicht mein Fall.
Ähm,
aber aktuell ist es mit Anlegen, finde ich,
gar nicht so einfach.
Also, so klassische Sachen anlegen kannst
du ja nicht, es gibt ja für nichts Zinsen. Du kannst ja im Endeffekt
eh nur Aktien, ETFs
oder sonst was kaufen, aber ich hab keinen
schimmer davon.
Ich bin zwar der krasse Hacker-Man, aber von sowas
hab ich keine Ahnung. Oh!
Erwerker hat das neue Emote erkannt.
Hier, wir haben ein neues
Emote. TooSmartFFZ.
Äh, too
smart, äh,
warum findet er das nicht?
Too intelligent.
Nein.
Emotes. Public
Library.
Auf!
Mach hin! Die Seite ist wieder
exzellent schnell.
Man muss nur wissen, was man tut, ja, das ist bei vielen
Sachen so.
Too smart.
Ah, yes!
Was?
Ah, das ist Better
Twitch TV.
Das ist Better Twitch TV Emotes, das ist gar
kein FFZ Emotes.
Top Emotes, Shared
Emotes. TooSmart.
Excellent.
Da ist es.
Das brauchen wir noch. Guck mal,
da sind wir.
TooSmart, das brauchen wir hier noch. Ganz, ganz wichtig.
Äh.
What?
Was war denn das? Warum hat das
gerade gelaggt?
Warum hat das gelaggt beim Downloaden?
Denn mein Browser ist gefreezed beim Downloaden.
Was ist das denn?
TooSmart.
Ah, yes.
Ah, das passt doch gut.
Das gefällt mir, das hat was.
Patrick, ich glaube, das hatte ich mir sogar schon
mal angeguckt.
Also, das ist eine Sache, die
mir in Go echt fehlt.
GoGenerics ist huge.
Das hätten sie schon vor 5 Jahren machen sollen.
Hab gehört, dass
Wirecard-Aktien gerade gut laufen.
Was ist? Ich habe das null verfolgt.
Ich habe nur auf Twitter gesehen, dass das trendet.
Was ist da eigentlich los?
Was ist Wirecard?
Wirecard.
German Payment Processor.
Ist das sowas wie Paypal oder so?
Warum benutzt du
verschiedene Browser?
Ja, hauptsächlich verwende
ich eigentlich Chromium.
Ansonsten verwende ich verschiedene Browser, weil
verschiedene Browser verschiedene Dinge anders machen.
Teilweise Seiten anders rendern.
Gerade Firefox und Chrome sollte man immer mal
vergleichen, wenn man Web-Anwendungen macht.
Gut, und dass ich jetzt Vivaldi, Chrome,
Chromium, Edge und Gedöns drauf
habe, hat sich halt einfach so ergeben.
Zum größten Teil verwende ich Chromium.
Denen wird Bilanzfälschung
vorgeworfen, haben eine KPMG
Prüfung nach der anderen.
Was ist denn KPMG?
Internet ist...
Ah, Stonks.
Verstehe.
Irgendwie sind da 1,9 Millionen
Was? Nur Millionen? Ah, Milliarden.
Ah, excellent. Ich wollte gerade sagen,
1,9 Millionen steht da doch keiner auf.
Was sind denn
1,9 Millionen?
Das hat Montana Black in
Rolex-Uhren. Dafür steht doch da kein Mensch auf.
1,9 Milliarden ist was anderes.
Stonks.
Guck mal,
wir haben ein Stonks-Emote.
Das fügen wir hinzu.
Das brauchen wir als Emote, Leute.
Mal gucken, ob es geht.
Stonks? Noch nicht.
Aber ich habe es hinzugefügt. Bald sollte
das Emote funktionieren.
Spätestens nächsten Stream soll es funktionieren.
Ähm...
Gab es hier noch irgendwelche Sachen?
Wie gesagt, ich bin nicht so lange
auch nicht.
Spätestens 13 Uhr
ist Mittagessen da.
Mal gucken.
Bla bla bla.
Fährst du mittags immer heim?
Nee, nee, nee.
Aktuell ist kein Problem. Aktuell ist eh 100%
Homeoffice. Da muss ich gar nicht heimfahren.
FFZ
Autocompletion.
Generell Leute, wer nicht FFZ installiert hat,
das ist das beste Addon,
was es für Twitch gibt.
Du hast Autocompletion für Emotes,
du hast eine History im Chat.
Das ist das beste Emote, was es gibt.
Äh...
Addon, Emote, was auch immer.
Es kann Better Twitch TV Emotes und
FFZ Emotes. Also, excellent.
Besser als Better Twitch TV ist es.
Beste, beste
Twitch
Enhancement
Extension.
Captain Peng schreibt seine Betriebssystem-Klausur.
Ach, Berufsschule, Berufsschule.
Berufsschule ist ja nur wirklich...
Berufsschule ist ja
kein Ding.
Berufsschule machst du, ohne zu lernen.
Ich kann mich noch dran erinnern.
Ich glaube, das war auch eine Betriebssysteme
Arbeit in der Berufsschule.
Haben wir geschrieben.
Also, wie gesagt, ich habe ja für die
Berufsschule prinzipiell nichts gelernt,
außer ab und zu mal ein bisschen
für Wirtschaftssachen, weil mir das überhaupt nicht liegt.
Und ich kann mich noch dran erinnern,
wir haben die Arbeit gekriegt.
Das waren zwei Seiten.
Meiner Ansicht nach waren die wirklich...
Und ich habe einfach überall was eingetragen,
so kurz, wie es ging.
Nach einer halben Stunde war ich fertig,
habe so um mich geguckt.
Alle da sind so wild am Schreiben, wild am Schreiben,
wild am Schreiben.
Da habe ich gedacht, komm, scheiß drauf,
ich will mich damit nicht länger beschäftigen,
ich gebe es einfach ab.
Berufsschule ist von Arsch.
Berufsschule ist...
einfach.
Trotzdem hatten wir Leute, die haben es geschafft,
6er zu schreiben in der Berufsschule.
Ich habe euch ja schon ein paar Mal von dem erzählt,
der es geschafft hat, 2 von 100 Punkten
in der Datenbankarbeit zu bekommen,
weil er zweimal Create Table geschrieben hat.
Und das musste er erstmal schaffen.
Nicht 0 von 100, 0 von 100 verstehe ich,
2 von 100 ist wirklich Painschamp.
Wollen wir das Chat durchgucken?
Ne, ich habe alles beantwortet.
Ach, Betriebssystem an der Uni,
okay, das ist was anderes.
Das ist wahrscheinlich dann doch ein bisschen schwieriger.
Wo bloß?
Was hältst du...
Wobei, ich kann das eigentlich einblenden,
was er sagt.
Wo habe ich den Chat?
Was hältst du denn
von dem Vorschlag unserer Familienministerium,
dass man Vorratsdatenspeicherung für den Kampf
gegen Kindermissbrauch...
Wenn es, wenn es den Leuten
wirklich um den Kampf von Kindermissbrauch
gehen würde, dann würde ich ja sagen, okay,
kann man da mal drüber diskutieren.
Leider werden solche Sachen immer vorgeschoben,
um es aus anderen
Beweggründen einzuführen.
Und das finde ich, gerade das finde ich
in dem Kontext schlecht.
Und den Hang dazu,
alles weitere noch mehr zu überwachen
und das Ganze noch lascher zu machen,
entgegen dem, was die Bevölkerung
eigentlich haben möchte,
äh,
gut,
da muss ich halt mal wieder das Bundesverfassungsgericht
mit beschäftigen und sagen, gibt's nicht.
Ich meine, es ist, ich habe letztens
eine Statistik gesehen, ähm,
um wie viele neue
Gesetze und Sachen sich
das Bundesverfassungsgericht kümmern muss.
Und man hat gesehen, seit, seit
1900 oder seit
2000, nee, nee, nicht seit
1995, ich glaube seit 2005
oder so in dem Dreh, ist das krass
angestiegen. Also sprich, die Gesetze
müssen mittlerweile so dermaßen schlecht
sein, dass sich das Bundesverfassungsgericht
mit so vielen Gesetzen beschäftigen muss
wie noch nie und es wird immer, immer mehr.
Also die, die, die, die Qualität
der Gesetzgebung ist wohl nicht
die, nicht der Wahnsinn die letzten
Jahre gewesen, wenn man sich die Statistik
so anguckt. Muss mal suchen, ob ich das,
ob ich das finde.
Ist dann wirklich gut, dass seit 2005
ging das da oben.
Stonks, yes.
Ahoi aus der Ikea-Schlange, excellent.
Mittwoch Flugzeugbeifahrer
freitags BWL Logistik und die Woche
darauf Flugantriebe. RIP.
Das klingt nach
Big Brain Studium.
Ja stimmt, hast du die Maske
auf. Ich habe übrigens meine
Maske immer noch nicht,
ich glaube, ich habe irgendwas von Cosplay geschrieben.
Genau,
Metro Cosplay.
Ich habe meine Maske immer noch nicht verwendet
für irgendwas. Jetzt habe ich die am
Start, ne, und ich habe sie während der ganzen Corona
Zeit nicht einmal verwendet.
Noch kein Metro Cosplay.
Ne.
Hat er das gesagt?
Ja.
Immer noch alle Filter verpackt, sonst
war es, ja.
Für nichts verwendet bisher.
Ja, wir wollen noch mal kurz gucken, was für
heute Abend prophezeit wird bei der Apple,
bei der Apple, bei dem Apple Event.
Also iOS 14, da gehe ich
ganz fest von aus.
Mac OS 10.16 juckt mich
ehrlich gesagt null.
Wäre aber nur logisch, dass auch
eine neue Mac OS Version kommt.
Den geht langsam
die Namen aus, glaube ich.
Das kommt
als nächstes.
Apple hat ja gerne irgendwelche Landschaftsdinger.
Streamst du das Event? Ja,
19 Uhr. Also ich hoffe, man darf
das restreamen, aber ich habe das letztes Jahr auch gemacht
und das hat
keinen interessiert.
So, Software Rumors.
WatchOS 7.
Ist mir vollkommen egal.
Vollkommen wurscht.
Ja, das mit
Arm erwarte ich eigentlich auch, Patrick.
Fragt mich, warum hier gar nichts drinnen steht.
Schlechte Predictions.
Ja, also das mit Arm
ist nahezu sicher, dass das kommt.
Diesmal ganz ohne Applaus
und sowas. Das ist ja ohne Publikum.
Ja, mal gespannt. Mal gespannt,
was da rauskommt. Also heute ist das
ich glaube 19 Uhr.
Ja,
genau, 19 Uhr.
Ja, wir stimmen alles zu.
Ja.
19 Uhr.
M-E-S-Z.
Es ist ja nicht nur so,
dass das mit Zeitzonen an sich schon
vollkommen wirr ist.
Jetzt werden Zeitzonen auch noch in unterschiedlichen
Sprachen unterschiedlich abgekürzt.
C-E-S-T
hast du. Das ist Central Europe
Summertime und das ist
mitteleuropäische Sommerzeit.
Das ist so hardcore pepega, diese ganze
Zeitzonengeschichte.
Weiß ich echt nicht, was ich dazu sagen soll.
Das Schlimmste ist für Leute,
die irgendwelche Date-Time-Libraries programmieren
müssen, die haben vollkommen gelitten.
Ich habe euch doch schon mal die Story
erzählt, dass Schweden den 30. Februar hatte,
oder?
Schweden wollte ihr
Kalendersystem umstellen, also das ist schon eine ganze
Weile her, keine Ahnung, 60 oder noch was oder so.
Schweden wollte irgendwie ihren
Kalender umstellen und
oder vielleicht, ich glaube sogar ein bisschen
später war es. Und
Schweden hat es verkackt, den Kalender umzustellen.
Und weil sie
Krieg geführt haben in der Zeit, haben sie gesagt,
ah ne, jetzt können wir jetzt keinen Kalender umstellen.
Und dann ist ihnen danach wieder eingefallen, oh fuck,
wir wollten den Kalender umstellen. Ah ja gut, dass wir
jetzt aufholen, machen wir einfach mal den 30. Februar.
Deswegen war Schweden, glaube ich, das einzige
Land auf der Welt, was jemals den 30. Februar
hatte. Ja, 1712.
Die Schweden, ja.
Die Schweden, guckt euch an, die haben echt
verkackt, ja.
Heute ist hier
Big Brainstream, ihr lernt mal wieder was.
Können wir MonkaGun durch
MonkaShoot ersetzen? Was ist denn MonkaShoot?
Ist doch genau das gleiche.
Achso, ah der schießt.
Ne, wir haben schon zu viel animierte Gifs.
Gibt es kein DIN für
Zeitzonen? Es gibt ISO.
ISO gibt es für Zeitzonen.
Und ähm
UTF?
Ne, nicht UTF.
Und wie heißt's?
UTC.
Nicht UTF.
Fast.
Einfach so ein paar Buchstaben Unterschied machen können.
Wie findest du ARM?
Für mich war das ein Grund, weshalb ich mir das
neue Surface Pro nicht geholt habe.
Mir ist die Architektur unter der Plattform
eigentlich ziemlich wurscht, solange es
die Software gibt, die ich haben will.
Was interessiert mich als normale Anwendung,
ob das ein x86 ARM oder sonst was ist?
Wenn es natürlich dazu führt, dass
die Software, die ich haben will, nicht drauf läuft,
dann finde ich's kacke.
Ne, das kenne ich noch nicht, aber ich kenne
von irgendeiner Entwicklerkonferenz einen Vortrag
zu dem Thema, wo es um Daytime Libraries
geht und wo er das halt auch erzählt hat,
dass die Schweden den 30. Februar hatten.
Ach ja, habe ich euch eigentlich
erzählt, ich habe gestern Abend
eine Mail
bekommen, wohlgemerkt
at wublaws und nicht
at maxfps, also
explizit Anschrift
für meinen Twitch-Stream.
Also jemand, der nicht über YouTube draufgekommen
ist, sondern über den Twitch-Stream.
Und ich habe ein Angebot bekommen
für, ihr werdet es nicht glauben,
RAID SHADOW LEGENDS!
Ungefähr 500 Dollar
aufgerundet.
oder irgendwie sowas haben sie geschrieben.
Ungefähr 500 Dollar
für
Advertisements.
Ich habe aber keine Ahnung, was die
wollen.
Also was die wollen, dass ich mache.
Und außerdem habe ich keinen
Bock, mit denen was zu machen.
Das mache ich nicht.
Ich fand es aber cool, dass ich
wirklich mal at wublaws was
gekriegt habe.
Ne, ne, ne, ich mache kein RAID SHADOW LEGENDS
Advertisement.
Auf keinen Fall. Kack-Game.
Angeblich haben die ja in ihrem
Vertrag drin stehen, dass man
enthusiastisch das Game anpreisen
muss. Also man kann jetzt nicht einfach
sagen, hey Jungs, also hier
RAID SHADOW LEGENDS Mobile Game
wer es mal Bock hat ausprobieren,
probiert mal aus.
Nein, die wollen von dir, dass du sagst,
Leute, ich habe hier dieses geile Mobile Game
entdeckt, lasst mich mal. RAID SHADOW LEGENDS
das ist ein Fantasy
RPG Cross-Platform
Mobile. Das gibt es sogar für den PC und
mein Gott, was man in diesem Game alles machen kann.
Ich glaube gar nicht, wie geil das ist. Wir gucken uns
das Ganze jetzt, also das wollen die ungefähr,
dass man das so macht. Also wenn
ihr Leute auf YouTube gesehen habt, die das so oder
so ähnlich machen, ähm,
dann haben die den gleichen
Vertrag unterschrieben, den
alle kriegen bei RAID SHADOW LEGENDS. Da steht
unter anderem drin, man soll das
hypen, das Game.
Oder enthusiastisch
soll man, enthusiastik
soll man das vorlesen.
Excellent. Ist das
nicht mega der Müll? Ja, das ist Hardcore-Müll
das Game.
Schlimmer als Windows.
Das ist totaler Crap
RAID SHADOW LEGENDS.
Ach ja, und die wollen auch, dass man bei den
äh, Edward, also bei der Werbung,
die man macht, dass man sagt,
oh, dieses Spiel erinnert mich so sehr
an gute alte Rollenspiele, endlich
gibt's sowas jetzt auch für Mobile. Das ist kein
Witz, kein Witz. Sowas
in der Richtung soll man da sagen.
Weißt du, dass die Entwickler aus dem
Casino-Business kommen? Nö. Aber
das wundert mich nicht. Guckt euch die ganzen
Mobile-Games an. Das sind ja zum größten
Teil Glücksspiel-Simulator.
Kennt ihr noch den Coin Master?
Erinnert sich noch jemand an den Co-
Sogar Bibi spielt den Coin Master.
Oder ist der Coin Master,
Alter?
Der Coin Master, Mensch.
Wie sieht's da eigentlich aus? Coin Master.
Android Store.
Was hat denn das aktuell so für Bewertungen?
Warum hat dieses Scheiß-Game
viereinhalb Sterne?
Ach so, ja, ich weiß. Weil die Leute
umsonst Ingame-Währung kriegen für positive
Bewertungen. Man darf
nicht vergessen, ich glaube, das ist verboten.
Aber juck Google nicht.
Ich bin mir ziemlich sicher, dass es
verboten ist, quasi
Store-Wertungen zu kaufen.
Der Coin Master.
Jaja, guck mal da hier.
Excellent Game. Viereinhalb Sterne.
We are sorry to
hear you are not enjoying our
experience.
Das ist ein absoluter
ein absoluter Bullshit
Unding-Marketing-Satz.
Was genau soll
dieser Satz sein? Okay, es tut uns,
also Kimberly, es tut uns leid,
zu hören,
dass du hier nicht unsere Erfahrungen,
dass du nicht sparst an unserer
Erfahrung. Was? Wie will man das überhaupt?
Was ist das überhaupt für ein Satz?
Hätten die geschrieben als Scheiß-Experience einfach
You are not enjoying our game. Da wär's
ja okay gewesen. Aber dieses ganze
Experience-Gelaber da immer.
Wo hat das eigentlich, wo hat das eigentlich
die guten Bewertungen her?
Wo hat denn das Game die guten
Bewertungen her?
Also für mich sehen die Bewertungen jetzt
nicht so gut aus, wenn ich ehrlich bin.
Aus time in
life
I am isolated
and homebound to my
hells. Coin Master is
welcome distraction. I love the game.
Ja, alles klar.
Wenn man daheim ist, weil man krank
ist, ist natürlich das Beste, was man
spielen kann, Coin Master natürlich, was sonst?
Depp1899
sagt, mich würde mal interessieren, wieviel
Lita Bohlen und Pietro Lombardi für
Coin Master bekommen haben. Okay, Pietro
Lombardi, keine Ahnung, ob das irgendjemand
für den Menschen noch interessiert.
Wahrscheinlich hat der jetzt nicht so wahnsinnig
viel dafür bekommen, aber für solche
Sachkriege gibt's eh relativ viel. Lita Bohlen
hat sicherlich massenhaft bekommen.
Was mich aber viel eher interessieren
würde, ist, was Ninja für den Wechsel zu Mixer
bekommen hat.
Das ist eigentlich die Sache, die mich interessiert.
Coin Master, was Bibi
und so von Coin Master gekriegt haben, juckt
mich nicht. Mich würde interessieren, was Ninja für Mixer
bekommen hat.
Weil ich bin mir nach wie vor ziemlich sicher,
dass Ninja das
quasi der
hauptsächliche Grund bei Ninja war,
dass er ausgesorgt hat danach.
So nach dem Motto, das war der Deal für die Rente
im Endeffekt. So nach dem Motto, ich
mach das jetzt und egal was passiert,
ich muss nur wieder arbeiten gehen.
Das würde mich echt
interessieren. Ich kann das unglaublich
schwer schätzen, was so jemand wie Ninja
bekommt für den Wechsel.
Der hat davor schon ausgesorgt gehabt.
Da bin ich mir nicht so sicher.
Aber spätestens nach dem Deal.
Man möchte ja vielleicht auch
einen gewissen Standard
halten. Und dafür ist so ein Deal über ein paar
Millionen sicherlich nicht verkehrt.
Naja.
Was ist denn heute
so in der IT-Welt passiert? Gibt es da
irgendwas Spannendes, was man wissen muss?
Wie rassistisch sind unsere Algorithmen?
Oh ja, das habe ich mich schon immer gefragt.
Juckt mich überhaupt nicht.
Die Bugs und das drohende
Zwangsupdate. Okay.
Warum drückt der eigentlich auf Windows 10 drauf?
Was ist der Sinn von
auf Windows 10 draufdrücken mit dem Finger?
Da müssen wir mal
Anton Wattmann fragen.
Vielleicht versucht er Windows auch
rauszudrücken aus seinem Rechner.
Ja, aber selbst wenn das Touch ist,
an die Stelle zu touchen macht überhaupt nichts.
Ich muss übrigens
demnächst auch updaten.
Thunderbolt.
Habt ihr den riesen Shitstorm
um The Last of Us 2 mitgekriegt?
Die Leute sind voll
am eskalieren. Gerade
wieder mal.
Kann ich sie verstehen?
Diesmal verstehe ich es. Und wisst ihr,
was ich cool finde? Dass die Leute mal
ausnahmsweise
nicht wegen irgendwelchen sinnlosen
Sachen eskalieren, sondern
weil das wirklich
fragwürdige Story-Entscheidungen hat.
Ich sage jetzt nichts, also ich werde euch nicht spoilern.
Das hat wirklich
eine sehr merkwürdige Entscheidung,
wo ich mich frage, hä?
Warum hat Naughty Dog so komische Dinger gemacht?
Ich spoilere euch nicht, keine Sorge.
Es gab natürlich auch wieder Leute,
das fand ich besonders geil,
es gab ja auch wieder Leute,
die gesagt haben, nee, nee, nee, storymäßig
ist das alles okay. Alle Leute,
die das Spiel schlecht finden, sind nur homophob.
Beste Begründung überhaupt.
Die Leute regen sich über die Story auf.
Nee, nee, das kann nicht sein.
Aber
ich habe mir Let's Play angeguckt
und
also nicht komplett, so die wichtigsten
Sachen und ich muss sagen, ich fand
die Story auch echt merkwürdig,
was sie da getrieben haben. Also ich werde es
nicht spielen. Oh!
Excellent!
Pearl 5.32!
Da habe ich ja drauf gewartet.
Endlich!
Write only! Vielleicht schreiben die
was sinnvolles, was erwartet
wird. Was wir
vom, okay, was wir erwarten.
Also, Zeit mal her.
Nee, nee, ich, äh,
Deadlift, ich erzähle hier nichts im Stream.
Das Spiel ist noch zu neu und viele wollen es noch spielen.
Das haben wir schon gesagt, das wird heute erwartet.
Da gehe ich auch fest von aus.
ArmDub, da bin ich auch ganz fest
dabei, dass das kommt.
Plüsselfinder.
AirTags.
Das Zeug.
Juckt mich,
juckt mich nicht.
IT-Produktmanager.
Stonks.
Oh, guck mal, es gibt einen neuen Grafiktreiber für Raspberry.
Das ist nicht schlecht.
Irgendwie nicht so spannend, was da heute
am Start ist. Ich habe übrigens meine VM gar nicht an.
Fällt mir gerade auf.
Da sehe ich im Zweifelsfall noch irgendwas.
Hab gerade Apple Werbung.
Ja, gerade heute muss Apple viel Werbung machen.
Nein, jetzt nicht.
Gerade heute muss Apple viel Werbung machen,
dass viele Leute gucken. Wo gibt es denn überhaupt
den Stream?
Mal gucken.
Stream, wo gibt es denn den heute Abend?
Außerdem gibt es den im Stream auf YouTube.
Okay, wo ist das?
WWDC. Gibt es das auch auf Twitch?
Apple Event Twitch.
Was?
Ah, 5 Follower, alles klar.
Lull.
Moment.
Es gibt WWDC als Kategorie
auf Twitch. Sehe ich das richtig?
Es gibt eine offizielle
Kategorie für das Event.
Okay.
Can Co stream WWDC?
Da bin ich mal gespannt.
Oh.
Morgen KS. Aber ich habe letztes
Jahr auch gestreamt und es hat keinen interessiert.
Und ich gehe auch mal stark von außen.
Es interessiert keinen.
YouTube.
Ja.
Ne.
Apple YouTube.
Wo gibt es denn das heute Abend?
Apple.
Bestimmt hier.
Ja.
Bin ich eigentlich?
Okay, ich weiß, wenn man so die Frage stellt,
dann erwarte ich, dass man sagt, ne.
Aber bin ich der einzige,
der die Apple Avatare übelst
...
Nicht hässlich, aber
so
...
Unpassend ist auch nicht das richtige Wort.
Irgendwie so billig
findet. Billig.
Ich finde die sehen übelst billig aus.
So richtig low.
Wie als hätte das irgendein
irgendein
irgendein Blender Tutorial Typ
gemacht.
Ich finde die übelst hässlich.
So nett hässlich.
Billig finde ich die. Billig
sehen die aus.
Die Apple Avatare.
Wie Avatar Apple.
Die Xbox 360 Avatare.
Ja.
Gibt es den eigentlich noch?
Xbox Informatic Core.
Warte mal.
Das bin ich nicht.
Xbox Profile.
Kann man danach suchen?
Moment, wie ...
Wie sucht man nach
Xbox Live, Leute?
Live Profile Search.
Geht das?
Ich wollte mir eigentlich mal ein Xbox Avatar mal angucken,
wie der aussieht.
Kann man?
Tag Search? Geht das?
Das ist ne Scam-Seite. 100 Pro.
Okay, ich blick da nicht durch.
Beide Microsoft-Geschichten.
In der Windows 10 Xbox App.
Dass man das schon mal nicht öffentlich verlinken kann,
ist schon wieder richtig Hardcore-Fail.
Ja.
Langsam krieg ich Hunger. Ich muss kurz was trinken.
Die Xbox 360 Avatare,
die waren cool.
Und mit der Xbox One haben sie es voll verkackt.
Da gab es die Avatare noch im dritten Untermenü
vom dritten Untermenü.
Und das hat sich keiner mehr für interessiert.
Die Sachen waren richtig cool auf der 360,
weil du auch in Spielen Sachen freispielen konntest.
Ich hatte dann ...
Mit meinem Avatar hatte ich das Super Meat Boy T-Shirt an
und so ein
Left 4 Dead Medipack.
Und das fand ich richtig nice,
dass das so integriert war.
Oh nee, please help.
Erst mal hier ausmachen.
So.
Gibt es noch irgendwelche Sachen?
Ich habe jetzt logischerweise,
nachdem es quasi Mittagspause-Stream ist,
nichts Großartiges überlegt.
Gibt es heute irgendwas Neues auf Hacker News oder so?
ARM, Mac, Impact und Intel. Ziemlich groß.
Nginx UI.
Okay, das klingt nicht schlecht.
Aber da kann man doch anscheinend gar nichts machen drin.
Na super, das ist eine Webseite
mit einem Text-Editor drauf.
Das brauche ich auch nicht.
Wozu ist das denn?
Das ist ja komplett sinnlos.
Moin, xjelaman.
Excellent.
Ein Winky-E-Mode fällt mir gerade auf.
Nix zum Winken.
Aber wozu braucht man ein Winky-E-Mode,
wenn man Coggers hat?
Browse service.
Browse modern web on historical browsers.
Okay, excellent.
Wo ist die Demo?
Internet Explorer 5.
Keine Demo.
Da gucken wir es uns nicht an.
WireGuard ist jetzt in OpenBSD drin.
Das ist cool.
Oh, heute ist ja nix passiert.
Es ist ja absolut Residenz-Liefer hier.
Ist ja nix los.
Das wird ganz kurzer Stream, ja.
Wie gesagt, nur Mittagspause-Stream.
Spätestens 13 Uhr, wenn das Essen kommt, ist es vorbei.
Es ist ja heute nichts passiert.
Ist ja mega langweilig.
Hat jemand einen Tipp für ein RSS-Feed-Programm?
Nö.
Ich glaube, ich habe die letzten 10 Jahre
keine RSS-Feeds mehr
benutzt.
Riko, wie darf man sich das eigentlich
vorstellen?
Riko sagt, ich habe es ja gerade
weggeklickt im Chat, hast du mitbekommen,
dass MeToo jetzt auch auf Twitch ist?
Wie darf man sich das vorstellen?
Machen jetzt Leute Streams,
wo sie erklären, wie sie Frauen
schon belästigt haben, oder was?
Allein schon, dass man defaultmäßig davon ausgeht,
dass jeder Mann irgendwie Frauen schon mal
belästigt hat, ist doch schon mal beknackt.
Ich wette mit euch, die meisten Männer haben noch nie
Frauen belästigt. Warum sollten sie das auch machen?
Es gibt dann die...
Ich will gar nicht wissen, dass das jetzt
auf Twitch ist oder nicht.
Die Themen, die umschiffe ich mal einfach.
Kannst nur verlieren.
Wir kümmern uns lieber um Big Brain
Themen.
Excellent.
Guck mal.
Das ist ja richtig gut. Man kann
relativ gut umschalten von hier
zu hier. Also ich kann jetzt
demnächst sagen im Stream so nach dem Motto, richtig
Big Brain Idee und dann kann ich umschalten auf
Excellent.
Ach so ist das, Nico. Okay.
Ja, das finde ich natürlich nicht gut.
Aber die einfachste Variante
darauf zu reagieren ist
Bannen. Natürlich wäre es
schön, wenn sich auf Twitch oder auf
Twitter oder auf YouTube keiner mehr gegenseitig
beleidigen würde. Aber
nachdem das nicht vorkommen wird, das einfachste ist
einfach alles bannen, was dir auf den Sack geht.
Oh, Rico, das guck ich mir jetzt
nicht anders. Da explodiert mein Gehirn wieder.
Es gibt nur so viel...
Es gibt nur so viele Sachen,
die ich...
ertrage am Tag,
was diese Themen angeht.
Nee, nee, ich schau mir das jetzt nicht an.
Es gibt so ein paar Themen, da mache ich in letzter Zeit
einen Bogen drum. Wisst ihr, früher,
früher, da habe ich immer noch so den Hang dazu
gehabt, alles, was irgendwie einer
verlinkt hat. Ich meine jetzt nicht Rico explizit
dich, so allgemein.
Alle Links, die man gekriegt hat und
egal, wo man schon wusste, was der Content
war, habe ich früher
immer angeklickt. So nach dem Motto, oh, was ist da dahinter?
Lass mal her. Und heute mache ich so,
wenn ich weiß, schon ungefähr, was
hinter dem Link sein könnte, manchmal sage ich
ganz bewusst, nee, das gebe ich mir heute nicht.
Sei es jetzt die üblichen
Diskussionen, die es so auf Twitter gibt,
oder auch, wenn Leute irgendwelche Videos
posten, posten,
wo ich im Vorfeld schon weiß, das ist abartig,
wenn man sich das anguckt, ja.
Also du musst ja heute im Internet nicht lange suchen,
dass du Videos findest von Leuten, die...
mit denen der Kopf platzt, um es jetzt mal extrem zu
sagen. Und wenn ich
so einen Link irgendwie sehe,
oder wenn der irgendwo gepostet wäre und ich weiß
schon, was da dahinter sein könnte, denke ich mir, nee,
muss ich mir heute nicht geben. Ich klicke nicht
mehr alle Links an.
Ihr könnt mich mit Links übrigens nicht
jebaiten, weil ich habe einen
Preview-Plugin,
was mir die Seite quasi
ohne JavaScript
zuzuladen previewt,
bevor ich sie aufmache, also
keine Chance.
Einfach zu Big Brain, ja.
Nee, nee, nee, Nico, das Thema diskutieren wir
jetzt nicht im Stream, da habe ich heute echt keinen Bock drauf.
Ich bin immer begeistert,
wie viele Leute, die iPhones haben,
Siri verwenden. Ich habe zwei iPhones. Ich habe noch
ein altes iPhone 6, das ich
verwende, mobile, und noch ein
iPhone, was ist das, SXXXS,
oder was auch immer,
wo keine SIM-Karte drin ist. Und auf
keinem der Geräte habe ich Siri aktiviert.
Siri, get out!
Piss dich
also! Direkt
deaktiviert, ja.
Ich glaube, eine der sinnvollen, also
eine der wenigen sinnvollen Sachen, wo ich
Siri verwenden würde, ist, wenn ich
beim, äh,
keine Ahnung, beim, beim,
wenn die Leute Auto fahren, oder irgendwas,
also sprich, wenn man die Hände nicht frei hat,
und dann sagen möchte,
ey, was weiß ich, wann ist mein
nächster Termin, oder sowas, oder
anrufen, oder das, das ist irgendwie sinnvoll.
Aber für die alltägliche Bedienung
tippe ich viel lieber auf
Display. Ich weiß, richtig, richtig,
richtig
Boomer.
Äh, Kruste können wir machen, die
sacken. Außer bei LMGs.
Timer für die Pizza
erstellen, ja.
Kannst du eigentlich für Nicht-IT-Menschen einen Browser empfehlen?
Wie für Nicht-IT-Menschen?
Nicht-IT-Menschen sollen einfach das
verwenden, was jeder verwendet, Chrome oder Firefox.
Könntest du
nen ViewBot, oh, das ist ne gute
Frage, ähm, da kann ich mir
meinen Senf zugeben. Könntest du nen
ViewBot skripten? Geht das überhaupt? Ja, klar funktioniert
das. Das erste,
wenn man sowas machen will, ist, man muss
sich überlegen, wie werden Viewer gezählt?
Das ist wahrscheinlich von
Plattform zu Plattform unterschiedlich.
Also werden Viewer pro Session
gezählt, äh, pro, was
weiß ich, pro Browser-Tab,
pro Verbindung, pro IP
oder sonst was. Das ist das erste, was man sich
überlegen muss, äh, sprich,
um nen ViewBot zu kreieren, wie könnte
man, wie zählt
die jeweilige Seite Views?
Ich vermute mal, dass es Twitch pro Verbindung macht,
weil wenn ich
mehrere Tabs aufmache auf nen Stream, der
keine Zuschauer hat, dann hat
der danach mehr Zuschauer.
Also ich vermute mal, dass pro Verbindung.
Oder, oder,
pro Session, pro Tab, oder wie auch
immer, äh, wird's wahrscheinlich bei Twitch
sein. Und dann ist es ziemlich einfach
ViewBots zu programmieren. Also wenn es wirklich,
äh, wenn das wirklich pro
Session, beziehungsweise pro Tab ist,
dann ist es einfach. Aber ich könnte
mir vorstellen, dass Twitch nicht,
nicht blöde ist.
Und, ähm,
das limitiert.
Also dass Twitch so ne, so ne doppelte
Logik hat, so nach dem Motto, okay,
es wäre logisch, dass
bis zu 10 Leuten pro
Haushalt quasi
jetzt, äh,
unterschiedliche Streams gucken auf unterschiedlichen Geräten
und die das trotzdem limitieren. Also wenn
du quasi von einer IP ausgehend
jetzt, ähm,
500 Mal den gleichen Stream
aufmachst, dass das
dann, oder auch 500 unterschiedliche Streams,
dass das Twitch checkt und sagt, nee,
das kann nicht sein.
Also die haben da bestimmt schon ne gewisse Logik dahinter.
Äh, aber selbst, also,
aber, sagen wir mal so, sollte das
nicht der Fall sein, dann ist es total einfach.
Dann ist die
aller einfachste Sache, das sind, das sind, äh,
10 Zeilen Code, wäre es,
nen Embedded Chrome zu nehmen,
oder nen, oder nen Chrome Scripting,
Chrome Scripting, ähm,
Plugin, äh,
nicht Plugin, Chrome, Chrome Scripting,
äh, äh,
Library, und einfach
in nem Headless Chrome,
500 Tabs aufzumachen.
So, das braucht zwar RAM und so, ist nicht die beste Variante
dafür, das wäre aber ziemlich
easy. Aber auch
sehr einfach festzustellen.
Ähm,
äh, sollte das irgendwie ein bisschen
Magic im Hintergrund haben,
mit, ähm, Fingerprinting
und Absender-IPs
oder sonstige Geschichten,
dann muss man es wahrscheinlich
ein bisschen komplizierter machen,
und im Zweifelsfall muss man das auch
über irgendwelche Proxy-Server
machen, oder VPNs,
wobei VPNs ist schwierig, da hast du auch
nicht unterschiedlich viele IPs.
Dann ist es einfach so, du, du gehst
irgendwo hin und fragst irgendeinen krassen
russischen Hackerman, ob er dir Zugang
zu seinen Botnets gibt,
und, äh, machst da drüber Viewbots.
Das dürfte dann tatsächlich das einfachste sein,
anstatt sich selbst da irgendwas zu basteln.
Es wird vor allem auch da gar nicht so billig.
Das heißt, im Endeffekt müsste man,
müsste man,
sich dann, keine Ahnung, jeweils ein paar Server
mieten, die billigsten Server,
da gibt's, reicht ja aus,
so ne, so ne 2 Dollar im Monat, äh,
VM, müsste man sich da ein paar
mieten, überall auf der Welt, und gucken,
wie viel man maximal damit dann generieren kann,
pro IP, oder pro, ja,
das, da müsste man schon ein bisschen, äh,
bisschen, ähm, Gehirnschmalz
reinstecken, aber ich denke mal,
im kleinen Maßstab, so bis zu
400, 500 Viewern, sollte man das
recht gut hinbekommen
können, bis Twitch das Ganze rauskriegt,
bei richtig großen
Sachen, wo dann auf einen, wo dann auf einen Schlag,
keine Ahnung, 3-4.000 Viewer kommen, oder so,
dann, äh, sollte doch sich
lieber der russische Hackerman mit seinem, ähm,
ähm, Botnets
da ranmachen. Ja, Stripes
007, ich weiß, aber ist die Frage, bis zu
wie viel Viewern das geht. Ich denke mal, Twitch
hat schon ne Logik, also er
schreibt hier, also mein Pi kann 4
Streams öffnen und zählt auch bei jedem als
Viewer. Ja, ich glaube, Twitch
hat schon irgendwo Limits, wie viele
Viewer von einer, von einer Sache ausgehen.
können. Shitsubi, du kannst davon
ausgehen, da ist definitiv nicht safe.
Viewbots zu
detekten ist
ziemlich einfach, statistisch
gesehen. Also wenn du auf
wenn du, wenn du auf einmal,
also wenn du ein Channel bist, mit normalerweise
5 Viewer, und du wirst
nicht gehostet, oder
irgendwie sonstige Shoutouts auf
auf Twitter von großen Channels,
oder auf Twitch oder sonst was, und du kriegst
aus dem Nichts auf einmal 500
Zuschauer, dann ist das verdammt offensichtlich
ein Viewbot. Da guckst du einfach, wo die
ganzen IPs herkommen, ob es da verschiedene
Muster in den Requests gibt, und
das kriegst du relativ einfach
raus. Die Sache ist dann nur die,
und das ist das, was es schwierig macht,
ähm, und das ist was es
schwierig macht,
Most Interesting Number Compassion, okay, das
können wir uns gleich nochmal angucken, und das ist was es
schwierig macht, was ähm,
äh, was Viewbotting angeht,
du kannst den Channelbetreiber nicht bannen.
So ohne weiteres.
Weil der Channelbetreiber kann
ja einfach gewiewbottet werden, ohne
dass er irgendwie was für kann.
Das kommt ja auch oft genug vor, dass
die Leute, äh, sagen, huch, warum hab ich
auf einmal 500 Zuschauer, weil
irgendeiner nen Viewbot angeschmissen hat.
Du kannst ihn ja nicht einfach bannen dafür, vielleicht
kann er ja gar nix dafür, das ist schwierig.
Haben diese
Viewer auch alle nen Twitch-Account? Wahrscheinlich nicht.
Du brauchst ja kein Twitch-Account.
Okay, Most Interesting
Numbers Compassion, okay.
Das ist das,
das klingt, das klingt nach
excellent Big Brain Video.
Das ist das beste Emote, Alter.
Negative One, okay.
Class Integer,
ja, ja.
Wohlgemerkt,
unsigned, äh, äh, signed
Integer, nicht unsigned.
Oh, jetzt wird's aber Big Brain.
Das ist, das ist, das ist zu high IQ
für die Mittagspause.
Excellent.
Alles klar.
The Gauss.
Ah, yes.
Jetzt wissen wir Bescheid.
Alles klar.
Der Euler ist ganz schön oft dabei.
Da fehlt 69.
Kommt noch 69?
Gut, dass das drin ist,
ist klar. Ah!
Wenigstens, wenigstens ist der
gerade drin. 420,
da muss es natürlich auch drin sein.
Number of the Beast.
Warum, ey, warum gibt's das Video?
Die Sinnhaftigkeit
des Videos hat sich mir jetzt
nicht so ganz erschlossen.
Aber das heißt ja nix, ne?
Ja, äh, muss ich wieder anmachen?
1337 hat
gefehlt, ja. 360 No Scope natürlich
auch. Gut geeignet
für die Grundschule. Excellent.
Ja, aber so viel zum Thema ViewBot.
Ich glaub, da hab ich mich jetzt lang genug drüber ausgelassen.
Ha!
Exposed.
Ja, guck, ich werf das an.
Das ist übrigens
verbuggt, dieses, das Plugin für die
Ah, da ist überhaupt
kein Hackerman dahinter gewesen.
Tja. So, Apple Event.
Heute Abend, 19 Uhr, geht's los.
Bin echt gespannt
drauf. Ähm,
vor allem,
ob man streamen darf. Ich werd's einfach
mal machen und gucken, was passiert.
Programmierst du mal
einen im Stream?
Ja, aber auf
Mixer dann. Seit wann
streamen die auf YouTube?
Haben die, glaube ich, letztes Jahr auch schon gemacht.
Ich bin mal gespannt, ob's wieder
nen Monitorstand für
ob's wieder nen 1000 Dollar
Monitorstand gibt.
Announcement. Wo ist das?
Das war das Highlight
vor letztem. Die haben ja sogar das Video
gelöscht, ne? Ähm,
oder wollten, dass das Video gelöscht wird.
Das
war ja klar.
War ja klar, dass es dazu einen
gibt, ey.
Moment,
Moment, der geht immer.
Moment, wird's
kickenlauter.
Okay, das
geht mir zu schnell. Also, was?
Okay, langsam.
Head Marketing Guy called me. Okay.
.
vor allem vor allem bei dem monitor stand gab es
dieses video von dem einen ecke zeigte dass die schrauben abbrechende
ernsthaft
ist auch gerade
das war
klar
das ist dazu ein gibt er das geht sie
sieht das apple 2020 aber gibt es
bestimmt gibt es bestimmt nach der
keynote heute reaction content auf
youtube es wird mir für immer ein
rätsel sein warum reaction content so
beliebt ist
das ist wahrscheinlich so wie boomer die
nicht verstehen was an let's plays gut
ist ich bin wahrscheinlich zu alt dafür
um zu verstehen was an reaction content
gut ist
du reagierst auch stehe ja natürlich da
reagiere aber auch ich warum sich das
leute angucken kann ja auch nicht
verstehen wenn ich auch was reagiere
aber wenn ich reagiere reagiere ja
wenigstens ich werde nicht verstehen
warum man sich reaction videos anguckt
bei manchen sachen gebe ich zu bei
manchen sachen wenn das irgendwas
kontroverses ist oder irgendwas was
besonders drama ist gerade ja okay dann
gucke ich mir auch mal irgendwas an wo
einer darauf reagiert
wo ich von dem ich vielleicht denke okay
interessiert mich was er dazu zu sagen
hat aber bei diesem 08 15 zeug keine
ahnung unge reagiert auf haft nicht
haftbefehl auf tanzverbot der sich eine
pizza bestellt oder sowas wo ich denke
who cares also erst ist mir schon
vollkommen wurscht dass ich tanzverbot
eine pizza bestellt selbst wenn sie
konkrefter pizza ist und drittens dass
der unge darauf reagiert könnte mir
nichts nichts egaler sein
irgendwie ist das voll angesagt aber da
bin ich wahrscheinlich zum
alt für das zu kapieren
wie gesagt es gibt auch viele boomer die
nicht checken oder eigentlich bin ich
ja selbst in der richtung puber was so
will die nicht verstehen was anders
plays gut ist sie sagen warum guckt man
sich letztes place an anstatt das ganze
selbst zu spielen da geht es ja gerade
darum dass man es nicht selber spiegelt
reagieren mal auf unges reagierungen
okay das heißt dann würde ich auf einen
reagieren der auf was reagiert der was
reagiert das muss man das muss man mal
unge unge hat doch bestimmt hat doch
bestimmt reagiert auf in scope 21 und
und wie heißt der andere gabel immer
stimmen gabel kann das sein reagiert auf
karl s der auf sie reagiert so und wenn
man darauf jetzt reagieren wird das
wäre dann quasi quadruple reaktion die
reaktion auf einen der auf sie reaktet
darauf reagiert ein und darauf würde ich
reagieren
das ist reaktion vielleicht vielleicht
könnte ich bin mir nicht sicher aber
vielleicht könnte es auch gerade
deswegen sein dass ich leute quasi
react reaktion channels oder react
sachen raussuchen die quasi das denken
was die leute auch denken und sich
quasi darin bestätigt fühlen dass der
reaction channel auf die art und weise
reagiert
wie sie wahrscheinlich auch reagiert
hätten versteht ja was ich meine falls
wir da irgendwann wollte gerade willst
du millionen views machen reaktion auf
komander kriegers tauch video big brain
idee
ich glaube eine sache die tatsächlich
zumindest zumindest bei den leuten die
schon eine weile dabei sind was einigen
tatsächlich gefallen würde ist wenn ich
auch auf meinen uralt video von mir
reakte so ich reagte auf mich reagte auf
den ultra skiller hey das war das kam
im stream ultra gut an ich habe mal im
stream auf den ultra skiller reacted das
fanden die leute ganz toll
wie hast du unten in der taskleiste so
nice flächen das ist dass ich
standardmäßig ich habe gar nichts
gemacht also das sieht doch immer so aus
oder sieht das nicht immer so aus die
leute sieht meine task leiste anders aus
als bei euch ach so ich glaube ich weiß
was du meinst doch doch eine sache habe
ich gemacht ja ich glaube das ist das
was du meinst das da musst du machen combine taskbar buttons wenn du das ja
wenn du das hier an machst dann hast du sowas und ich glaube das ist die fault
dass du quasi dann chrome quasi so als eigen hast das ist aber müll ich will
die einzelnen anwendungen sehen ich glaube das ist das setting was
versuchst ja dass das das ist das ist total total lame will das hier auswählen
können weil ansonsten musste ja erst einmal da drauf drücken und dann da
drauf drücken das ist total von arsch einfach ja die zubi bei dir ist das
gruppiert ich mag das 0 ich schalte das überall aus wo ich es
ausschalten kann und ich will des songs gucken wir uns jetzt nicht an kommt
eigentlich mal was um die channel
points auszugeben naja ich hab's euch ja das letzte mal
vorgelesen was ich moment moment wir gucken wir gucken noch mal was es für
möglichkeiten für channel points gibt ich lese euch mal noch mal vor was es
für channel points sachen gibt falls ich falls ich finde partner punkte punkte
kanal punkte drops ich kann drops einschalten
übrigens mein sound ist gerade weg ich hör' ich weiß kein sound der leute hallo
hörte mich doch dort inhalte mich noch gehört mich doch
ich glaube man audio interface packt also ich hab' ich höre nichts mehr hier
manchmal kurz das чисlesia financialhеруatmas Любorgen
du sagst alles ihr zeitbuch bitcoin
hallo man hört mich doch wir hören uns ja ich habe aber den gp falls specke ist
ob der bank will ich machen narrative den geist ansprechen für reminders und sharing
ich ich bin grad ich finde die einstellung nicht was es für wen ist wenn ein book oder
nicht was es für kanal punkte gibt wir hatten das das letzte mal hatte ich doch
schon gefunden kanal und videos creator dashboard wo kann man auswählen was man
für was wo kann man aussehen was er für die kanal punkte macht partner bestimmt
der partner partner auszahlmethoden emotes treue abzeichen inhalt community kanal punkte
da ist es okay belohnung verwalten also was hat man was was haben wir zur auswahl also
nachrichten davor haben wir individuelle belohnung erstellen kann man kann sich
sogar selbst was ausdecken was man machen will hat er jemand big
brain idee für selber timeouten wo ist denn da der sinn aber das könnte das kann
ich das kann ich euch echt wenn ihr euch selber timeouten wollt rufe die sammlung
auf okay ich sperre dich vorübergehend belohnung hinzufügen excellent für 2500
punkte belohnung hinzufügen okay so leute ihr könnt euch jetzt selbst
timeouten wahnsinn big brain das das haben wir gebraucht
but why leute warum timeoutet ihr euch das ergibt doch überhaupt keinen sinn
excellent big brain chat alter warum timeoutet ihr euch chat ich weiß gar nicht wie lange das geht
selbstmord im chat alter es hört ja ist ja hier chat hört auf chat lasst
bleiben der chat beginn selbstmord so okay ich guck mal was es noch für belohnungen gibt
ich guck mal was es noch für belohnungen gibt ich aktiviere zwei minuten lang nur
den emote modus nee das ist langweilig eine umfrage vorschlagen schlage eine
umfrage vor die im stream ausgeführt werden soll
okay das ist nicht schlecht für 7500 lasse ich da anzeige laufen ich lasse
nie anzeigen laufen füge einen befehl deiner wahl hinzuordnen das ist keine
gute idee für 10.000 punkte kann man jemand anderen timeouten
nee für zehn minuten sogar sperren lassen und das ist das ist fies das mit
den umfragen ist nicht schlecht das mache ich noch mal rein aber das
können wir heute nicht machen weil ich wusste in zehn minuten auf so was
könnte man denn für custom was könnte man dann für custom
irl belohne deine zuschauer indem du sie anweisungen geben lässt die du vor der
kamera befolgt lass mich daten und nein also außerdem welche kamera
liege stützen sit-ups nein garantiert nicht für 2500 da komme ich ein stream
nichts anderes mehr raus als set ups zu machen spiel bezogen du darfst ein
charakter oder gegenstand eine stadt im spiel benennen
individuelle belohnung ok was kann man da für name der belohnung beschreibung
zuschauer muss text eingeben kosten belohnungs bild einlösen pro stream
begrenzt
Einlösen pro Stream, speichern, okay.
Das Memeboard steuern.
Das ist in der Tat eine richtig gute Idee.
Allerdings müsste ich das erst einbauen.
Das ist eine gute Idee.
Memeboard, Emote deiner Wahl.
Ein Emote deiner Wahl einblenden oder irgendwie sowas.
Einmal.
Ja, das Memeboard erweitern, da habe ich gerade keinen Bock drauf.
Das würde ich dann von Hand machen.
Und ich habe nämlich keinen Bock an meinen eigenen Dreckscode mehr ranzugehen.
Das würde ich dann von Hand machen, wenn das einer einlöst.
IP-Leak für Kanalpunkte.
Big Brain, ja.
Snapchat.
Only Fans, nicht Snapchat.
Snapchat ist out.
Only Fans.
Was mache ich? Snapchat User Statistics.
Snapchat ist nicht mehr so angesagt, oder?
Snapchat ist nicht mehr so angesagt.
Nicht mal so der heiße Scheiß, ne?
Nee.
Snapchat ist nicht mehr so krass, ne?
Also ich meine, in diesem Umfeld ist ja, wenn man nicht doppelt so viel Wachstum hat wie letztes Jahr, ist schon schlecht.
Oh, was ist denn das hier? Das sehe ich ja gerade zum ersten Mal.
Ist das Archiv am Start?
Guck mal da, Leute.
Ist das Archiv? Es gibt sogar Archivsuche hier.
Clips?
Spiele?
Teams?
Oh, man kann jetzt sogar die Oberfläche ändern, oder was?
Hohohoho.
Excellent.
Okay, Streams.
Suchbegriff.
Äh, Kekwe.
Alles durchsucht, nur die Clips, oder?
Oder durchsucht das auch die Streams?
Nee, nur Clips.
Streams.
Okay, BF3.
Nee, die Streams durchsucht es noch nicht.
Aufwachen, da gibt es auf jeden Fall Streams.
Nee, Streams durchsucht es noch nicht.
Excellent.
Das Archiv wird ja immer besser, Leute, hier.
Am meisten gespielt haben wir Just Chatting, gefolgt von Science & Technology, danach Talkshows und Podcasts, danach Creative und dann Overwatch und BDO, Battlefield, okay.
Verständlich.
Hey Max, ist Chromium up to date?
Ja.
Ja, ist up to date.
Hat sogar einen Updater dabei.
Ja.
So Leute, es gibt jetzt gleich Mittagessen.
Ich werde mich jetzt vom Acker machen.
Heute Abend, 19 Uhr, gucken wir uns zusammen, also in 6 Stunden, gucken wir uns zusammen das Apple Event an.
Und mal gucken, was dabei rumkommt.
Wir sehen uns, bis dann, macht's gut, see you.
Was gibt's zu essen?
Äh, Mozzarella Sticks mit Pommes frites.
See you.
Tschüss.